you guys said the chemistry test between  you all was so intense what made it  intense was that i was auditioning for a  batman movie i felt like i was still  auditioning yeah you get so close to  something that you want so bad it's  intense and you're trying to act like  it's not a big yeah and i'm trying to be  like i don't care  the intensity is really trying to mask  all the nerves the ending of this movie  does leave the door open are you  interested in suiting up again yeah for  sure i was talking to matt about it  yesterday and it's funny because he's  like yeah we've been talking about  sequels i'm like who have you been  talking about to sequels i mean i really  wanna kind of like can i be out tell me  what the sequel is you're the last to  know definitely and i love the cast in  there i mean i love working with matt  i'm just so proud of the movie and you  know it'd be so fun to do it again